[Music]
Hello, welcome to Papo na Arena, the
weekly podcast where we
share ideas and discuss content we've
read, listened to, or watched, always bringing a
product perspective and discussion. I'm
Artur, and I'm very excited about
today's guest, and I'm X, and I'm
also excited because today's guest is
someone we've mentioned dozens of
times here on Po Cash, right? She
worked at Maquin, went through Guia
Bolso, worked for many years at Pia
Seguros, and that's where she had the biggest
challenge of her life, which was putting up with me
every day working with her.
So welcome to Papo na Arena,
Alice Gcias introduces herself to the group. Hey
everyone, how are you? It's going to be a pleasure to be
with you here today, another day
putting up with AX. In my career, I'm from
Bahia, I studied electrical engineering at Unicamp,
and ended up going to France for
two years where I started to have
my first contact with technology.
I did a postgraduate degree in
information systems and also did an
internship in Quality Assurance, and
when I returned, I started my
career in...  I spent two years at McKinsey
doing strategy and
operations projects, including strategy in
operations, and then I did a
THIOT program, which is when you spend a year away from
here while you study for an
MBA and things like that, and end up going to
Guia Bolso, which is a
financial management startup.
My first two years were
in product, then I spent another
two years in operations where I ran the
credit operations of Gua Bolso, and from there
I went to Pia Seguradora where I ran
four areas: product, strategy,
pricing, risk acceptance, and the
operations side of both
automobile and cell phone products. I took
a sabbatical in the meantime, and
now I'm a Venture Partner at
Canary. Okay, let's get to our
questions, Artur. Okay,
and here's this intro, just
easy stuff, but let's go. Alice,
you talked a lot, right? Like, you
spent time at McKinsey and stuff, and
before you actually went into the world of
product, technology, startups in general, how
was that transition for you,
and what skills do you think you...  What skills
did you develop during your
consulting period that helped you, and what skills do
you think you lacked that you
had to work hard to develop? Well,
I think what helped me the most
was the ability to structure
problems and really understand the
problem. The first step to
structuring a good problem is
understanding what the problem is, so I would
say that's the main one, and there are
others that help. So when you're
in consulting, you work a lot on
stakeholder management, which is
a necessary skill. When you're
developing a product, you work a
lot on communication, whether it's up-to-top or down-to-down.
You should use
each of these communication styles, whether
you want to use it more for persuasion or
more for explanation, to help the person
reach the same conclusion as you. These are
two different ways of
building your reasoning. So I would say
that what I inherited from consulting
were these skills, and what I
lacked most was the ability to test
quickly, to have a mindset more focused on putting
things out there and seeing the results. I remember
in my first year I was doing
analysis and my boss was looking at
me and asking why I didn't...
So, this vision of "what do I
have to test, why do I have to test
this, and how do I test this
efficiently?" is something I've
had to develop over
time. And maintaining this
same subject, right? Background
experience, consulting... I know
you're a profile you like to
bring to product teams, right?
You've already talked a little about what
those experiences were like, how they
helped you, right? What do you think PMs
who don't come from a
consulting background should focus on
developing? What does this profile bring more of, you
know? And what does the market perhaps not train
as much as consulting
does?
I'd say the main points are
understanding the problem in depth, structuring the
problem—I think this part is
more important than resource management—and
communication, and the other is business sense.
So generally, PMs who don't come from
consulting have these two skills
that are lacking, right? And this
directly impacts the ability to prioritize,
which for me is the most
important ability of a PM. So I'd say that's
it for you to achieve...  Well, just like a
PM, there are other skills you need to
have, right? I mean, a PM has to be a
generalist in everything, and because they're a
generalist, they have to be able to
gather knowledge from
all areas to
prioritize very well. This involves having
Business Essence, it involves
customer service, it involves
technology support, and even a
little understanding of marketing. It's
impossible for someone to be deep in all
these areas. So, for me, they have to be able to
be superficial in all of them
to prioritize very well. And
to prioritize very well, you also have to be able to
structure the problem very well.
And I think that's it. When
you don't have Business Sense, sometimes you
prioritize too much in a customer-oriented way, but
how does it impact the business when you
don't structure the problem well, and
often the problem is
n't even being solved, right? And I think it's even worth
going into this part of Business
Sense, right? Tell the people what you
understand about Business
Sense. What difference does that make to a
PM's work? I think you even gave
an example. Sometimes the person
prioritizes the product too much, too much the
customer too, not prioritizing the business, right?  In
situations where one approach works
better than another, or where you should lean more towards
one side, right? For me, Business Essence means
you have to understand where the
business is going, why it's going there, what
the competitive advantages are, what it
wants to create, what
its market positioning is. You have to
understand all of this, understand
how your business stays afloat, what
the levers are that make it stay
afloat, and then your prioritization
varies a lot. You always have to
understand the customer; you should always
be doing things that ultimately
improve your customer's life, otherwise you
won't sell your product to its full potential. But if
you do something that's so good for the customer
but doesn't make the business stay
afloat, it doesn't work either. So
many times it's a balance in relation
to these things, and I think that to
understand where you prioritize, you have to
understand what your
business vision and your product vision are. So
at Pier, for example, when we
talked about making instant CL, it was
something exceptional for the customer.
So imagine your cell phone was stolen, you
receive it instantly. From a
business perspective, it's also super interesting;
we were doing CL analysis.  In a
100% automated way, we
managed to automate 20% of the claims, and
one of the things that made
our business stop progressing was being more
efficient than the market so we
could have a better customer. So it was a
prioritization we made that
impacted both parties. When we looked at
our sales funnel,
we greatly improved it to make it
easier for the customer
and also increase conversion.
So it was good for both of us. There are
cases where you can't reach
that point, for example, in
car claims; you need more time
to analyze the claim. So we
always debated how
to have an instant
car claim, and we never managed to
arrive at that design. Because, if the
car was stolen, we need to know
if we'll recover the car or not, right? But then
we thought, what could be
relevant enough for the customer for
us to automate and try to make it
instantaneous? So, for example, "Your
claim is already approved; if your
car isn't found, you'll be
paid." So it's not 100%, but you...  It starts
doing something that's more focused there, and
you try to find a good PR mix,
both of them, right? And taking advantage of this topic, I'd like to
remind you that there's a
course on
critical and analytical thinking, and
we talk a lot about it, about
business, about understanding business,
financial metrics, economics, and how to
make all these connections. Oh, and
causalities, like this: on the 29th, you can go
online live, and on July 6th, in person
here in São Paulo. And the discount, as
always, is in the link in the description here. And
another thing that also has to do with
critical and analytical thinking, which
we talked about in the podcast, where we went
deep into this subject, right? So if you
want to delve deeper, a couple of episodes
ago we did a program more
focused on that, but it has a lot to do with
problem-solving skills, right? That you
also mentioned, Alice. Alice, I already
mentioned this in the podcast; it was the
person who helped me develop my
problem-solving skills who said, "Dude, you have to
put this in your PDI, look, it's this, this, this, and so on,"
and then she kept sending
everyone to talk to me so I could
help people.  Because I had to
study this, right? And it's much easier to
tell people how you
learned something than something that's innate
to you, right? And it's a recurring topic
here on the podcast. I wanted you to
talk a little bit, Alice, about the gaps
you usually see in PM (Problem Solving) regarding this.
What do you think they can do
to improve in this aspect? Well, the
gap I see most often is people jumping
straight to the solution. So instead of
thinking about structuring the problem, understanding
the problem more deeply, they say, "We
need to improve X." And then the person
starts saying, "Hey, we can do
all this to improve X." Okay, but what does
doing this mean? Is it
helping the client? What
business problem is it solving? In
general, what problem is being solved
by doing this? And I think there are
several ways to develop
problem-solving, and I've
studied this topic quite a bit.
You can ask him for several tips.
I think in one of the
previous programs, I left the DOC that I got when
I made it, so I'll
put the link in the description of
this edition as well. I really like a
concept that...  70% of your learning
comes from doing something,
so the way you learn
something best is by doing it, right? So, let's say 70% comes
from there, 20%
comes from seeing how others do it, and
10% comes from studying. I read this
somewhere, I don't remember the
reference, but what I remember is more or
less this division. And if you think about it,
what takes more work is studying. On one
hand, studying gives you a foundation, which is
very good, but I think it's very
important to
balance how you're learning
things. So, for me, the best way to
learn problem-solving, and how
I usually try to learn something, is I
start by talking to someone who is good,
I try to apply it, and then I study.
Because when you start studying,
my view, my perception is that you
don't feel the pain, you don't yet know what
you're not going to know. And then you see
so much that you have to
study that sometimes it even paralyzes you,
you say, "My God, there's so much in this
topic!" And when you start executing,
you start saying, "Hmm, but I'm stuck
here, I'm going to study this," and then you
are much more efficient in your study.
Studying is the most
time-consuming thing, even though it's where
10% of your knowledge comes from. It's what
requires the most time. So, it's a process
I generally like to do to learn
anything: talk to really
good people, try to apply what I've learned, and then start
studying in the places I'm stuck in to gain
a bit more
foundation. So I suggest doing this.
When I was learning problem-
solving, I'd go into a restaurant and
start trying to estimate what the
revenue was, how many people passed by per
day, anything. You can be walking down
the street, you can think about how many buildings are on
this street, you can call
anything, how many people
pass by here per day, how many... People like
that golf ball analogy, right? How many
golf balls fit in this room?
How many penguins are there in Antarctica?
Literally, how do
you estimate anything without having
references? This is a way for you to
practice problem-solving, and the ISO (Integrated System of Problem Solving) that you
learn, you test, you
practice, you learn. You're not going to
talk about misspellings... Oh, we can... that's a
concept, right? And there are several
concepts in problem-solving. We can talk
about trees, for example, that you love...
Right, Teresa Torres, whom you
loved, in the end, the structure of a tree is
for you to leave something connected, right? It's all connected. It's
also a
tree, when you're
brainstorming, it doesn't need to be MSE,
right? But a problem-solving tree
usually is, uh, but in
general it is MSE, which stands for mutually exclusive
collectively exhaustive, and it's the concept that
when you try to solve a
problem, it's important that it addresses the
whole, which is the collectively exhaustive, and that
it doesn't have any intersection between
them, which is the mutually exclusive.
It's difficult to understand when you say it like that.
My tip is to type MSE into Google,
put images, and they'll have two little
images there: cycles and E. That usually makes it
much clearer than
saying it like that. But it's something really
important. PR in the
PR part and the baker's calculation too, right? I think
all those examples you gave,
including how much revenue
this restaurant has, how many
soccer balls will fit in a room, you'll never
know exactly, right? But estimates and
baker's calculations help with that. It's a
relevant part of your problem-
solving. The next step is for you to be able to...
Prioritize. So, to prioritize, if
you try to estimate everything in
great detail, you'll spend
your life estimating. So I think a
super interesting skill to develop,
which also involves doing this type of
exercise, is back-of-the-envelope calculations. I'm
a bit traumatized by this topic;
sometimes I'd spend a whole day
doing the calculation, but I could do it in 5 minutes and
get a number that was close—not exactly the
same, but close.
But that came from a lot of practice, it didn't
come out of nowhere. But it's
important to think about how I
simplify this to
arrive at a good estimate. And back-of-the-envelope calculations are
also very useful for
double-checking. So, does this
number make sense? What
can I use as a reference to double-
check if this number
is directionally correct? And 90% of the time, the
number doesn't need to be exact; if it's
in the right direction, it's valid.
What changes is whether the conversion is 2% or
2.1% or 2.2%. So, if it's within a
reasonable margin of error, everything is
fine. What you want to know is...  If
the order of magnitude makes sense, and
baker's calculations are very good for that
too, the point you made about
baker's calculations helping with
simplification is that, in the end, they
help simplify not only the
calculations themselves. Because the better
you get at baker's calculations, the more
you simplify,
even for problems, the
solutions you'll come up with after
identifying the problems will become
much more practical. You
can start simplifying
things, logically within a good range,
sufficient to achieve
these simplifications, etc. It ends up
expanding much more than just
baker's calculations. And even so, I remember a
lot in presentations, we
had a weekly one where the leaders
would report on the
results we were seeing. I
found a lot of errors in
double-checking, doing baker's calculations, so
I'd look at it and say, "This number
isn't right, let's check
this, I don't know," and it was all baker's calculations
because I didn't have much else.
Sometimes they would do
elaborate analyses and then they would have made
some small mistake.  And sometimes these
simple calculations helped with that kind of
double-checking in everyday life, you know? I
think it gives you a great ability
to bring common sense to the numbers, you know, to see
if it's directional, people, saying, "Good,
very good," anyway. And throughout your
career, one thing you had to
do a lot was assembling and
organizing teams, right? Not just
product teams. And what are your tips for
leaders on how to create a
team structure? How to identify when to grow?
How to decide what profile to hire? Tell us
a little about Alice assembling teams.
Well, I think the first thing you
have to do is decide what the
organizational structure of your team will be.
And there is no perfect organizational structure,
so generally, every
structure will bring you benefits and
drawbacks. And then you have to understand
what you are trying to optimize with
that structure. So, for example, in
Pira, we could organize by
business unit, for example, automobiles, smartphones. We could organize the structure by journey, which is the benefit and drawback of each. If you organize by business unit, the great benefit is that
you have a complete view of your
product. So you have someone who
understands that product from end to end
and can optimize it.  Everything you
need from that product, what's the
downside? You don't have someone
looking at acquisition globally.
You don't have someone looking
at the customer journey
globally. And if the customer has both
products, what happens? Another problem
that arose when we were organized
by business units was that prioritization
occurred within the business units,
so it was harder to distinguish. "
Oh, I want to prioritize higher than
smartphones, how do you change that quickly?" It's
not trivial, right? Because the team is already
allocated. So every time you want to
make a prioritization change
regarding resources, it's more painful.
It was much easier if you
wanted to prioritize between acquisition versus
satisfaction. Because then, no, everyone on the
smartphone team
focuses more on acquisition or more on
customer dissatisfaction. And you have the
opposite problem when you're with
the acquisition journey and the
customer journey, which was our case. And
when you're organized by journey,
you don't have anyone seeing the product
end-to-end, so you also don't have anyone
who understands the product end-to-
end, so there will always be tradeoffs.
And then you have...  First, you have to think about what you
want to optimize, what you want to
maximize, and the second point is how
you reduce the problems. How do you
work through the problems that this structure
brings you? And then governance usually comes into play.
So when I think about governance, I
think about routines, rituals, and even a
structure of responsibilities that will
minimize the problems of your
organizational structure. For me, that's one of the
main objectives of what you do
in relation to the governance of your
team, which is different from
corporate governance where you have
other things you're also looking at.
So that's the first thing I
think about. And I feel that there are times—
I've seen some teams created without
this being so consciously considered.  Regarding
identifying the right time to
grow, there's a concept, I think, that
involves two things that are very tricky:
The more experienced a person
you bring to your team is, the more demand
they will generate, because
by design, that person has more vision. So
they see more things to do. It's
very difficult to bring a manager
to a team and have them not say they
need three coordinators; it's very
difficult because they will see
enough for three coordinators to do,
enough for
10 coordinators to do. If they don't
see all that, you
probably hired the wrong manager.
So I think there's one thing
to consider when you're
looking to grow: what level of
seniority will you bring to that position?
And how will you align expectations
with that person regarding the level of resources
they will have over time? If you
bring a manager to work with an
analyst, you have to create very well the
expectation for that manager that, well,
you'll only have a team with four or five
coordinators in hx years, okay?
You understand that you'll see
more things to do than that. And
I think understanding that
expectation...  Company growth
helps you understand what size
team you need at any given
moment, and the specific moment for
growth, I think, is much more a
matter of the company itself. What is the
company's strategy at that
moment? And that varies quite a bit. So,
if the company has
very high expectations of having
good cash flow, it makes a lot of sense to focus
more on product and
technology teams. If the company has
less cash flow, you'll focus more on
growing the operations team. So I think
the
team growth strategy varies a lot depending on the
company's current situation.
And then there's the missing profile to hire,
right? That varies wildly! So,
the profile has this
seniority aspect that I mentioned a little. I tend to
start with more senior profiles,
so the smaller the team, the more senior I
tend to start with,
because you want to give them autonomy.
And if you start by bringing in
very junior people to the team, you'll have to
take on a lot of decision-making. So I tend to
bring in someone a little more
senior who will create more legs, especially
since you don't have the structure.  If
you don't have a process, you have nothing
when you're building a startup very
early on, so you can't give
enough direction to someone
very junior. I think this
issue of profile depends on so many
things, right? What stage is the
company at? What stage is the area at? What does
this position require? It's kind of
difficult to talk about in such a comprehensive way, I do
n't know if you want to. I think there's
also an interesting thing, which is
complementary skills, right?
Looking at the skills the position needs
as well as the skills your team doesn't have, and
how you complement them, right? And
I think there are several
ways to look at what skills are.
I really like to look at BTI, for
example, M, BTI, which has that I, which is
introverted, extroverted; OOS, which is
a more detail-oriented person, a person
with a more global vision; FOT, which is
feeling, thinking; and P and J, which is a
person who sees more of this
process. So this is a way of
seeing complementarity because
generally these people see
different things.  There's the
complementarity of skills:
communication versus
problem-solving skills versus a
more creative person who can
also disrupt what you're
doing versus a stronger
leadership skill. You can
also look at diversity to
bring in different
perspectives. You can look at people
who have worked more in B2C and B2B, or
people who have
worked more in growth and
retention, which are more
specific jobs. You can look at someone
who has worked more on the topic you
want. So there are many ways to
look at skill complementarity. And
I think it depends a lot on your
team-building strategy,
understanding what your team needs,
where your team needs it, and how
you can complement all of that.
Bringing in someone... Sometimes it seems
simpler than it is,
but it's interesting to put this
puzzle together. Something you mentioned
that I remembered was also at
IUSE, which was an insurance company
a little before Pier, and
we had exactly that when
we were structuring the teams. That was the
first version.  We opted to have
each team for each Business Unit, so
we had a team that handled
high-value insurance, a team that handled expensive insurance,
and so on.
Then we broke it down and restructured it to
go by journey because after a while
we had learned a lot
about the products, which ones were the
flagship products, which ones weren't, and so on.
We said, "Okay, now we can
optimize things." In fact,
initially, sometimes even
assistance services that had different products
were the same assistance, but the
way to request and contract them was
different. Then we simplified
this by structuring it more in terms of the
journey. But you mentioned, I remembered that a
lot, how
sometimes what makes sense at one
point you'll have to go to
another stage, to another, to another
profile. There's also the question of how
you think about
mitigating these problems from the beginning. So, for
example, you could have a forum to
discuss the claims journey. You could
have a Journey Leader, a designer
who is a Journey Leader, who is responsible
for ensuring that it's the journey...  It's sinister,
she's minimally coherent. You can
make some changes to the structure and everything will be fine.
The only thing I advise
is not to overcomplicate the structure at the
beginning. Don't use a matrix structure
because of that; you'll generate so much
complexity in your business. This
will obviously depend on the stage
you're at. If you reach a stage where
your company has 3,000 people, use a
matrix structure, but if
your company has 100 people, don't use a
matrix structure because you'll
make your business so much more complex
that it won't be worth it. So, for me,
how do you create a little rock? You
can have a leader, you can have a
ritual, a routine, and that's why
this governance model, right?
Governance involves both rituals
and this structure that we
generally use, the RASS, right? The structure
of responsibilities helps you solve things, you
know? I agree a lot with that, but
thinking about these hacks is also super
interesting. Great! And now, talking about the
new moment in your career, you did
consulting, then operations and product, and
now you're a Venture Partner at Canary.
Talk a little about this role, what does
a Venture Partner do?  What is your
job? How's this
career transition going? You're transitioning in a
way, right? There are many
similarities there, but tell us about it. Well,
first of all, I was very lucky to get
this position. I started
studying theses to start my own company in June of last year.
My idea is to start
building my own company, and in that
process, I became very close to
Florian, who is one of the partners at Canary. I was
presenting the studies I was
doing, and he asked me how I viewed theses.
He said, "If I'm thinking of setting up
a research area here, what's
the concept of that area?" So, one of the
biggest challenges for a founder is
finding a thesis, and it's a
difficult challenge. Ultimately, they have a
better position than an individual to
find good theses.
Canary is constantly in
contact with funds abroad;
they receive many theses every day, so
they have a much more accurate view of what's happening
in the market than an
individual, and this generates the ability to
create good ideas. And what I do
today is explore these good ideas.  To
understand if they are really good or
not. So, despite having the
ability to expand on these good ideas,
they didn't have the ability to
delve deeper into them and understand if they make
sense or not. And now what I'm
doing is this, right? They have the ability
to take a ready-made idea and evaluate if
it makes sense or not, but not to
take an idea like, "Oh, should I do this
for sales? Does it make sense?" I don't know, at the
first level it seems like it does, right? How do
I validate it to affirm that it's a
previous step, right? From the validated idea?
Exactly. And so my role today
is to help set up this research area
with the main objective of helping
founders take the next step,
helping founders-to-be, right?
These are people who want to be
founders but aren't yet, but
my idea is to be an entrepreneur. So I hope
that one of these ideas I'll like so much
that I'll say, "This one is mine!"
So it was an interesting path we
found, of me helping a
need that the company had at the moment
and helping my career moment, which was
wanting to be an entrepreneur, combining the best of both
worlds. But it's been fun and there have been
some...  Questions here that I haven't
answered, so
what is a venture partner? A venture partner is the
most random role that exists in a fund;
it can be anything.
So it's the fund employee, right? They can
do anything. That's it. Each
venture partner you talk to will
do something different. So, it's
like, "This person is helping me with
something," that's what they mean. It's a
little different from an entrepreneur
residency, right? The entrepreneur residency
usually helps with a thesis
within the fund, while the venture partner
helps build something within the
fund. But I think in my
specific case, this research area has
been interesting. I've
learned a lot about how a fund evaluates
companies to invest in them,
how a fund thinks, and I think that
's also an interesting skill for
when I go into entrepreneurship. It's
also been very interesting for me to
learn and expand my network.
So I've talked
to many entrepreneurs and
investment funds, and it's something I
value a lot for this journey.
A shout-out here to
Floran; we could
call Flor over soon to say
hello too. And before we
get into the chat...  From the
quick questions segment, I often bring up a
phrase here on the show: "Work,
work, work." Don't forget that the
commas mean pause. And besides
consulting, you've worked at several
companies in a state of
accelerated growth, like Guia Bolso and Pier, and
you also spent a good amount of time
taking some time for yourself afterward,
taking a sabbatical. I wanted to understand a
little bit about how that process was.
What was the main sign that you
noticed it was time to
take a break? Tell me a little about
how it was. The company I
worked for the most in my life was Maquin. And there,
I think you're young, right? You can handle it, so...
and I worked a lot at Maquin. There were
projects where I worked
16 hours a day, it was insane. And then, at
Guia Bolso, when I went, the idea
was just to stay for a year, and I ended up staying
four. I went without taking any breaks, right?
And when I left Guia Bolso, I
had six consecutive years working with
few breaks. And then I said, "Man, I
need some time," and then I made a
deal with myself that I would never
leave a job again without taking time off.
For me, when you go on vacation while
working, you disconnect, but it takes
me
at least two weeks to disconnect. And it's not that common to
take two weeks of vacation; some
people take two weeks off, that's
normal, right? It's
not difficult, is it? Taking a whole
month off isn't really our style. I
feel like we don't have real time
to disconnect, and things are
happening, so there's always that little
worry, you know? Deep down, sometimes you
get a Slack message about something
more urgent, a WhatsApp message, so I feel like
when you leave work, it's over. There's no
worry, and I can't...
and for me, it's the best time
to enjoy that time.
So I have a very strong feeling about that
today, so it's less a question of when
I understood it; for me, it was
more a matter of an agreement with
myself, and I plan financially
for it every time.
[Music]
Okay, let's get to our chat. So let's go,
product management in a tweet...
this wasn't so quick, was it?
But it is... So, you who are good at summarizing...
Look, I would say prioritize... Understand
the risks... Understand how  To mitigate these
risks with simple tests, and what
is the main skill of a
product person? Good prioritization. Do you have any
books you recommend for people? It
doesn't have to be a technical
product book or anything, it can be
any book. I'm reading one now
called Dopamine Notion, it's Dopamine Notion, I do
n't know the exact order, but it's
Dopamine Notion, and it talks about
how our current society leads
us to have these
rapid dopamine stimuli, and what we
should be doing to
detach ourselves from these stimuli. I find it super
interesting and it's very associated with
all the stimuli we have today,
so I like it, I'm still
reading it, so I'm enjoying it. This book
is on my list, actually because it's
like if you subscribe to Audition Book, it's listed
as a book there that you can read for
free. I put it on
my list to start it. I
never, I always end up picking another
book and don't start it, but now I'm going to
prioritize it. I recommend it, it's
interesting. And what series are you
watching on...  Right now, Yellow Stone, or is it
that you guys... not now? Because that one's
on my list. The book was on
Arthur's list, and Yellow Stone is on my
series list. I just finished watching Band of
Brothers, which is very interesting, it's
about World War II, and
now I'm watching El Loston. Good. And
what's your favorite song, singer, or album? It
can be from the moment, it can be from my
life. I have a song that I use before
important meetings. This one is unusual, huh?
Kelly Clone's "Stronger" is my
Power Position song before
ISO meetings. That's a good tidbit, huh?
I think I already knew this at
some point, I completely forgot about
this information. It's very good, it really motivates me.
I do a lot of Power Position with
it, I jump, shout, then I go into the meeting and
dance. There's going to be a meeting with an investor, I
use it a lot. And it's something you don't
give up in your routine. I sleep well, I sleep 8
hours. I didn't sleep 8 hours, Jesus. And
you, do you follow gadgets like that to see how
your sleep was, etc., to
make sure it was going well or not?
I try to have a sleep routine, a
pre-sleep routine, you know.  Okay, so
generally, around 9 pm I try to turn off
all electronics. It's often the
time I'm going to read, do something
different, anything. Sometimes
I start cleaning the house at that time,
whatever. My neighbor must love it, right?
The neighbor who starts cleaning the house at
9 pm, turns on the vacuum cleaner, right?
But I try to start
turning off all electronics at 9 pm so I'm
asleep by 10 pm, and then I wake up at 6 pm. I
often leave a small crack in the
window open and wake up with sunlight.
When I wake up, I try to look at the light,
try to look outside to
get that stimulus from the day. This
also impacts sleep, right? So it's super
interesting that studies show that
this impacts sleep later. And I try to
start my day without my
cell phone too. So I often wake up, stretch,
take a shower, then eat eggs, eat
my fruit, then I go to pick up my cell phone.
So there's almost an hour that I'm
without it. And to finish our chat,
what's your favorite product? I like
audio, you know? It greatly increased my
ability to read, so "read" in quotes,
right? It's exactly "consume".
Reading content: Artur is a big fan too. Man,
I listen a lot, but one thing that bothers me is... I need
a hack for this, but I haven't figured it out yet. It
's about being
able to
save that part while you're listening to something without having to
pick up your phone, etc. I liked
this part here. Give it a highlight.
I'll look at it properly later,
but I haven't figured it out yet.
But wow, I read it, I can't help but
use the "read" function here, guys. I'm going to use the "read" function. Uh,
I read Barack Obama's book, you
feel like he's sitting next to you
telling his life story. I find that
impressive. This scheme they
used, where the author himself often
narrates the book, I think it creates a
very different kind of closeness because it's
him telling it the way he wants it told, you
know? It's not you reading it
the way you think he's
doing it. And I think that's
very interesting. So, I don't know, I like it a
lot. I think it brings a
bit of the strength of podcasts, you know, that
many people like podcasts because of
this closeness, people feel like
they're close.  ...from the
podcast hosts and such, and I think that's what
the Plus is all about, which is
a narrative, right? So it's what
you said, it gives the
narrative its tone the way the person wants. I really
like it, for me it was a
very good product. You mentioned
that, there's another book that's very
similar, "100 Days Between Heaven
and Sea" by Amir Clink, which is also
narrated by him and everything, and they say it
's very cool. Lucas, who's always
listening with us, even said he had
that experience when
he was crossing to Africa,
and that it was really awesome.
So it's really different, right?
[Music]
And with that, we conclude
today's program, another Hero product delivered.
So I wanted to take this opportunity, Alice,
thank you very much for your time, for
chatting with us. It was a great
program, I think our listeners
will really enjoy it. And if you want to
leave a final message for the audience,
something you want to share, the space is
yours, go ahead guys, it was a pleasure.
Here with you all. I hope you
enjoyed it. I hope that in some way I
can contribute to your
product journey. It was a pleasure being
here. Well, Alice, thank you very much for
participating, for all the lessons
you gave today.
So that's it, guys. If you liked it,
share it! This episode deserves to be
shared, not that the others don't
need it, but this one also deserves to be
shared with other people.
So add it to your playlist, share it
with your friends, follow us on social media,
both on Instagram, Twitter, and
LinkedIn @arena @ur close comk
@x. And that's it, see you next week! Thanks!